>>>DANIEL FRIEDMAN: Hello and welcome, everyone. It's
December 31, 2022. We are
here in the 2022 Active Inference
Livestream review. Welcome to the active
inference institute. We're a
participatory online institute that is
communicating, learning, and practicing
applied active coherence. This is a
recorded and an active Livestream, so
please provide us with feedback so we
can improve our work. All backgrounds
and perspectives are welcome. We'll be
following good video etiquette for
Livestreams Head over Active
Coherence.org to learn more about
getting involved in live streams or
various other projects and learning
groups at the institute. Well,
today is going to be great and fun.
We are simply reviewing our streams
from this past year. We're going to
touch lightly or mildly
on all the streams that we carried out
from 2022. And by
way of doing that, we may end up
reflecting and preflecting thinking
about where we're going to head in 2023.
So we'll begin with just an introduction
and a hello, I'm Daniel. I am a
researcher in California and I'm excited
to reflect. This is like the dot zero
preparation, dot one, dot two
discussion, and then afterwards we
reflect. This is like the bookend
reflection for all of those. And so it's
like an even deeper level of nesting.
When we're going to Juxtapose. So many
things that we talked about, and I'm
sure at some neural level,
whether somebody was familiar with the
streams or whether they listened to none
of them, there's going to be something
about just touching on so many topics
and so many perspectives being
juxtaposed that I think is going to be
really pleasant to you. Dean.
>>>DEAN TICKLES: Yeah. Thanks, Dean. I'm Dean. I'm here
in Calgary. Maybe I'm a revised or
recycled researcher. I don't know what
my title is now, but after Daniel
said, yeah, I think we should do this
again, I was like, yeah, we absolutely
should, because my metaphor is that it's
kind of like double frying those
French fries. It just adds an extra
layer of integration or crispiness
that's hard to resist.
The way that we present these things is
hopefully a way of integrating a bunch
of information because we talk amongst
ourselves and it's helpful. And then you
look back at yourself talking about
yourself and others, and you just get a
whole different perspective on it. So I
actually am really looking forward to
sort of running through these things.
It's going to be a sprint, but that's
okay. It still gives you a chance to
figure out what the milestones were.
It's like seeing the entire Tour de
France in 30 minutes,
which is kind of fun. It's like we
completed that marathon and now we're
high speed watching the recording from
our body camera. All right,
well, we'll keep with some patterns from
the more paper centric discussions,
like leading with big questions. So what
was our stream of attention in 2022 and
where and how will we stream in 2023?
What did you have to add on these
questions?
Not a heck of a lot. It'll be
interesting given the amount of time
that you committed to the endeavor of
here's 2022. I wonder what we'll fill it
with. I'm curious now that now that
you're on the back side of that, what
parts of what you hoped would be
achieved came about and what parts do
you think there's still room for some
backfilling? We'll come to that after
we've touched on everything.
Yeah. I really liked what you added
here, though. In a world that is
becoming more familiar with correlation
and digital mediums and spaces,
is our use of technology more than an
easy way to gain information access?
You can be in the library all you want
and you won't read a book. We can
have all the access to information in
the world and we won't necessarily
digest and incorporate. We can have all
the generative AI in the world writing
in these amazing essays and making art.
But where does that put us as
information forager and then you added,
can we turn figuring out into out there
figuring? And as more and more people
start to want to figure out active
inference, it's not a Rubik's Cube on
the table that gets finished.
And by putting it out there,
figuring is where active inference
are. So I think that's really exciting.
Like, we do have so much to figure out
from all backgrounds, and yet we
want to be out there figuring and having
impact. I think that's where your
background and field research and my
background in sending people out into
professional settings, they're very
different, but also structurally very
similar. There's no substitute for
actually picking yourself up. It's a
form of migration. You like you use the
word stingrate. Until I can actually
figure out what my pheromone trail is,
I'll let you have that piece of it. But
I mean, I understand it. I get it. And
yeah, let's see where it takes us.
All right. Roadmap.
So maybe we should have done like a rear
view mirror or something. But we had 87
streams in 2022. The live streams.
Table has 87 rows. So it
was an amazing year. And the numbers are
shown here. We're going to touch pretty
lightly on all of the streams from
two through nine. The roundtable
symposium, math stream, Jorge stream,
Twitter spaces, guest stream, model
stream, and bookstream. And then we're
going to slow down a little bit and talk
about some of the papers that we
discussed. So first, the overall review,
though, for a general
Institute level review, check out our
quarterly roundtable number four. So
that's where we talk more about the
Institute's directions, other projects,
and learning groups. But today we're
just going to talk about the Live
Streams. All right, what did
you write with these questions? Yeah,
I'm often curious because when you're
when you're busy constructing 87 rows,
when you reached whatever that limit is,
is there a big picture that has come
about as a result of that stack.
Again, it'll probably be something we'll
be able to answer better at the
conclusion of our chat today,
but I think it's something to try to
keep in mind. I don't know that we can
say with certainty that your big picture
and my sense of that same picture is the
same interpretation. But it's a good
idea to keep a sort of a general level
sense of so. Did this all come together?
Or how did the live streams intermingle
with some of the guest streams
intermingle with some of the bookstream
stuff that you and is it Tyler and Bleu
are looking at right now?
Yeah, well, the links here can
all be accessed through active
inference. And of course, one project of
note is the active inference journal,
where all of the live streams, through
the incredible work of Dave Douglas and
others, get transcribed,
archived and versioned up on the GitHub.
So that is one structural development of
the live streams. Is there a big
picture? It really can feel like just
moving pebbles back and forth, and there
isn't necessarily a vision of what the
final nest looks like. So I
hope we can kind of look back on it once
we've gone through it. All right, let's
jump in. First roundtables.
So we have a tradition of four quarterly
roundtables at the institute scale.
The first two one we'll notice are
ActInf lab quarterly roundtables,
and the third and the fourth are active
coherence institute roundtables.
Because in the middle of 2022, we had,
of course, our transition from being
active inference lab to active inference
institute. So here's an image meme that
we have from the fourth quarterly
roundtable and these roundtables the
screenshots with who's there and who
shows up, but also just what we
discussed are like planting a series
of flags in the ground and they're
an absolutely honest representation of
who we were and what we were doing then.
And so I really enjoy sometimes even
looking back and seeing how things have
happened. So that's not as
scientifically or philosophically
concept of a live stream series. And the
information in certain ways is out of
date because it's more of an
informative, participation oriented
communication, but nonetheless a great
series. And also, before we head in
and to avert saying this, of every
single series in stream,
big appreciation for those who had the
bravery and capacity to join,
whether they joined repeatedly or one
time, it's been awesome and it's
totally co created with the people who
are there in the most just unbelievable
ways. All right,
to the symposium. So this was our second
applied active inference symposium.
The focus was on robotics, and the first
applied active inference symposium in 21
was just with Karl Friston. It was a one
man show. And for this symposium, we had
some more elaborate developments. We had
some entorhinal co organizers in Matt
Brown and in Mark Miller. We also wanted
to Costa wide variety of speakers
and perspectives. So we had two four
hour sections with 12345
presenters in the first session and 1234
and a half with Friston joining in the
second session. And we saw
active states of the art in active
inference being applied to robotics. We
saw embodied actual robots. We learned
about some of the theory. We saw
connections to previous lineages of
robotics and also more general control.
Theoretic Brea each of the sessions
closed with a roundtable discussion,
the second one being more populous than
the first. And when people say like,
okay, enough about what active inference
is, how and where can it be applied?
And people commonly point to areas like
human health as well as robotics as some
of the leading areas in the recent and
in the coming years. And I'm just really
happy that we were able to highlight the
state of the art. Like, this is what
robotics and active inference looked
like in 2022. Publish a transcript,
make it citable, and give visibility
across these different sectors so that
they could connect on some of their
developments and also their ongoing
challenges.
Math stream. Yeah, go ahead. I hope
that at some point,
and I don't know, timing really matters,
but I hope at some point, people in
other more dedicated learning spaces,
like formal education spaces systems,
will find themselves asking questions
around how things that we've been
talking about and we've been interacting
on might complement the way
that things happen in those systems. So
it's not, let's go build a robot that
does x. It's actually taking the active
and the inferred and taking action
on hidden states as a complement
to we've got to get a certain
score on an Sat. I think it would be
very interesting to see when that coming
together on the horizon. We know that
the train tracks remain parallel, but as
we look at that, there's a name for
that. You probably know what it is, but
when it reaches that horizon, it appears
they've come together. So I'm hoping
that that isn't sort of lost in some of
these other initiatives that
I know would actually be easier
to do because there isn't such a history
and a whole bunch of people who are very
vested. In maintaining the status quo as
opposed to really journeying in ways
that are not discarding what we know,
taking the priors and allowing for some
new priorities. So just want to kind of
toss that in there. Awesome. Thank you.
We had just one math stream,
formerly with David Spivak
and Bleu, facilitating on category
theory. This is a
few train stops away for some of us
individually and for the field. But this
year there have been some incredible
advances in active inference and
category theory. So the field is being
fertilized and prepared for
an incredible regenerative category
theoretic implication of active
inference. But that's all we'll say for
now. Here in the streams
we focus on the intersection of active
inference and organizations. We had two
streams. First one was with Eugene
Leventhal from the Smart Contract
Research Forum, and the second stream
was with Bijan Hezri, whose book
Governing Continuous Transformation is
also the focus of the bookstream, which
we'll get to in a second. And both
of these were awesome streams.
There are hidden states for both.
All only say what all say, which is
that they both were incredibly
informative, and the Triangulation
active inference lab for both of them
was something that was incredibly
natural coming from,
as in Bijan's case, somebody with
decades of executive experience who
completed his PhD dissertation on free
energy governance and sees the framework
specifically as a vehicle for moving the
frontier of leadership in organizations.
Or Eugene, whose fluency
with internal and external organization
made it a natural and enjoyable
conversation. And we connected a lot of
topics of interest in online and web
three organization. So it was a great
time. Yes. If you
want to do something interesting, watch
the orchestra with Bijan and then
watch the live Stream series number 36
about modeling ourselves. And you'll
very quickly see that Bijan was close to
the end of the year. But many of the
things that he spoke of, we were talking
about in detail with one of the papers
that we took up basically a year ago.
That's the interesting that you don't
realize that until you're on a day like
today. Awesome.
We had one Twitter spaces. The title
was, can Web Three survive Without
Cognitive Modeling? It was a provocative
clickbait headline and we had
a chance on this discussion to talk
about the active block, for instance,
project with Yakup here as one of the
primary developers and advocates and
stewards of that project. And we
discussed this question, which is can
web three or cyber physical systems more
broadly exist in an increasingly complex
present and future without something
like cognitive modeling, for which we
believe active inference is the most
composable and flexible, generalizable
and powerful framework. So I forget
whether it's never ask a question in the
headline if the answer is yes or no, I
always forget, so I never know. So I
always approached those headline based
questions with an open mind. But we
had a good time in this discussion and
these kinds of informal formats might
have a lot of applicability. We didn't
really need to prepare much. There also
weren't any slides. So for those who are
interested in this genre of social
audio or whatever it is called, there's
a lot of opportunities for frankly just
interacting with people where they are
talking about active inference and
making the compromise in the improvised
moment. All right,
we had quite a handful of guest streams
from number 14 to number 31, so I'm
going to just briefly try to recall and
mention those who joined. Jorge Esteves
discussed osteopathy and mental health
in a 14, bobby Azarian in 15.1
and .2 discussed Universal Bayesianism.
Mark Solmes joined for 16, discussing
consciousness as precision optimization,
which also was published by the Active
Inference Journal in one of the most
manually crafted and beautiful
publications. Mao Albarasan spoke
in guestroom 17 about epistemic
communities under active inference,
which is an area of increasing
importance. Iain Robertson, Michael
Markov and Julian Kiverstein discussed
the literalist fallacy and the free
energy principle, where that was only in
March, it was on Pie Day, and we
reawakened the kraken of the
realism instrumentalism dialectic,
which I know that we're going to touch
on today again. 19 Markov decision
discussed extended predictive minds
ActInf lab Gueststream 20 Shannon Proach
discussed coordination dynamics of multi
agent interaction, and the screenshot on
the bottom left is showing a slide from
her presentation. I think it was an
amazing presentation. It's very
accessible and very cutting edge work on
multi agent active inference and also in
the very fun setting of music listening
and creation, so it was very engaging.
Adam SAFRON in guest room 21 discussed
free will. Anna Lemke in guest room
22 discussed Dopamine Nation, and that's
a fun one to view and share because Anna
comes from a psychiatry background,
not familiar with active inference too
much, but open hearted,
open minded and engaged with
real people and with research every day.
So we had a really affable conversation.
In guest room 23, Maxwell Ramstead and
Dalton Activity Devil joined for
rebooting the free Energy Principle
literature, which was a paper
discussed that was not the title of a
paper, but a paper was discussed that
got folded into the pre play for
Livestream. 49 so we'll talk more about
Bayesian physics then. Esteves Grossberg
joined for guestroom 24, explainable and
reliable AI and also a
commendation there to Ali, who did
incredible preparation and facilitation
as well as editing the transcript here
and made this an incredibly high quality
experience for everybody. Guestroom 25
Brett Anderson discussed the continuum
of traits between autism and Schizotype.
So that was kind of interesting work and
speaks to a lot of areas of meaning.
In guest room 26, along with my
colleagues at Common Sense Makers, Data
ShahF, Lauren Hebert, Ozan Tamari and
William Fisher, we discussed from users
to Sense Makers and about Stigmurgy,
which is cognitive behavioral algorithms
that modify the environment in the
context of sense making. ActInf Lab
Gueststream 27 was with John Verveake,
and we had a great time. We had a stool
with three legs, predictive processing,
relevance, realization, active
inference, and Dean and I were preparing
those slides. We had the stool going and
then we flipped a stool and it was
upside down and then that was just one
of many inversions and transformations.
And John has a very delightful
and mindful way of approaching dialogue,
as those who are familiar with his work
know, and so we had a great time
in 28, Giovanni Rolla discussed
reconceiving, rationality and active
cognition. Guest room 29 Shauna Dobson
on making up our minds. Imaginative
deconstruction in math art. For those
who are looking for the triple play of
math, art and philosophy,
there is only one unicorn in this
forest.
Guest room 30 with Kiritanatrades was on
the human governance Problem complex
Systems and the Limits of Human
Cognition. This was a very fascinating
presentation of an artificial
intelligence system that was churning
in the background while we had a
discussion. And so it was quite visually
and conceptually interesting.
And then most recently, in guest room
31, Brett Kagan and Adeel Razi discussed
biological and synthetic intelligence
from the free energy principle
perspective and some of their empirical
work with neurons in a dish playing
video games, and the way that they were
modeling that with active inference. So
we had a great set
of guest streams, and we look forward to
a diverse and comprehensive
set for 2023. So if you want to join for
a guest stream, or if you want to
recommend or introduce somebody, this is
very low bar. It can be a presentation
they've given somewhere else. Some of
these presenters requested us to do
background, which we're happy to do,
prepare questions, others just show up.
So if you think there's somebody who
could fit in well in a guest stream,
even if they're not in the center of the
active inference research developments
ongoing, we can absolutely make it
happen. Dean, what would you add on the
guest streams angle?
If I could invite five
people out myself at the same table,
and I could get Dalton and I could get
Shauna, yourself and John
Verbaki and me just sitting around and
just talking about stuff, I think I
probably would be about as good as it
gets. I think that would be just one of
the most amazing dialogues, and you
wouldn't know where it was going to go.
And that would be half the excitement,
is just people who
can basically have a conversation with
anybody about topics that are incredibly
sophisticated and yet seem to be able to
bring it to a level where, as you said,
it's engaging,
it's amazing. And this is not to
downplay all the other guests that were
kind enough to join, but again,
if I were to do something on a social
level, on an informal level, all of
these people, thank you to all of them.
Great. All right. In the model streams,
we like to highlight modeling,
and we had three absolutely
cutting edge presentations with
interactive components. Model Stream
Five with Pietro Masaglia and Tim
Verbelen. We discussed contrast of
active inference, which uses some
current threads in non active inference
machine learning like contrast of
learning, and brought it into the
context of active inference to
facilitate learning in noisy
environments. In Model stream Six,
Teofil Champion joined to discuss
his quite prolific and creative avenue
of research into branching time. Active
inference. And Yakup and Ali are here
also did a lot of background to prepare
and as we entertain larger and
larger state spaces and deeper and
deeper possible futures with more and
more and more affordances and
affordances on preferences and
affordance on affordances on
preferences, these state spaces become
vast. And things that you can write down
on the back of an envelope might take
all the heat in the world with current
computers to run. Just like you could
write down two large numbers and
multiply them, but you could look at
each number and it's just a number.
Well, you can draw a Bayes graph, and
yet to run that Bayes graph might be not
plausible. So there's a lot of relevance
in this area of research of finding out
these computational acceleration
methods. And Heuristics, as well as
even just qualitatively this idea of
branching time, branching and pruning
time, and what kinds of strategies are
used to branch and prune time
adaptively. It's very exciting. And then
in Model stream Seven, Conor Heins and
Daphne Demekas joined to discuss Pymdp,
which is rapidly becoming the Python
active inference implementation approach
of choice in the community. And it was
great because we were able to ask basic
questions, we were able to hear about
the intentions of the package. And we're
going to have a dot two in just a couple
of weeks. This is something in
terms of the package. It's something
where more and more of our work in the
Institute is going to use this package.
And the interoperability of different
generative, models and processes and
simulations written in Pi MDP is going
to facilitate the accessibility, rigor
and applicability of active inference.
So great work to all those who are
contributors on this package and
everybody who is out there applying
active inference computationally and
shared it with us this way.
All right. And the last non paper
Livestream is the bookstream. So the
bookstream is being led by Bleu
and Tyler Solberg. And when
they got a hand on Bijan Kezri's
book governing Continuous Transformation
reframing the Strategy Governance
conversation, they jumped on it and
they said, how can we do some kind of a
regular series? How can we increase our
accountability in reading and
understanding this book and also make
something for the community? And they
said, we want to do a weekly ish book
stream. So we've done that for the past
several weeks, and there will be many
more sessions to come, including
discussions with the author. So great
initiative, and it's
keeping the stove warm
on these topics of organizational
development, which are just absolutely
evergreen.
All right, on to the Paper
Livestreams, which we don't play
favorites, but we love the paper
livestreams. Go ahead,
Dean, start us with 35. Where were we
in January 22 when we were reading
A Tale of Two Architectures free energy,
its models and modularity by Sajid Beni?
I wish I could say that I looked a lot
younger back then, but I looked old back
then, too. I think a year ago
we were pretty excited because I
think it felt as though things
could go in a number of exafferent
directions and that we as a community
that were discussing a lot of the most
cutting edge on the sort of bow wave of
information that was coming out of
people's research. It kind
of felt like we weren't just
aggregating, we were actually kind
of one step removed. We weren't getting
too locked into any one particular facet
of this multifaceted idea.
And it
could really blossom into something like
what we thought was this kind of magic
acorn or unicorn or whatever. And how it
would be viewed 360
some days later, we didn't really know.
But we also weren't afraid to kind of
test the limits. That's what I felt 22
was more than anything else. It was an
opportunity to test things. And that
didn't mean that we were out to prove
people wrong. We just wanted there
was now enough information, a large
enough sample size, that we could do
some cross checking. And that sort of
allowed the people that were doing the
cross checking, the ones that were
reading this long list of papers, a
chance to kind of go, huh. Okay, well,
I think I've seen that over here, but
there seemed to be some hesitation
around how far that rule holds under
this set of circumstances in Yada yada.
So 350 started out
I've just put my notes here as a formal
treatment of what graphical modeling can
look like. I e. Our DAGs are
cycle list while DCM are cycle based.
And for me, the introduction of a term
joint probability. Up to that point, I
had never heard of that expression. And
we ended up using joint probability in a
lot of the papers that followed. So
there was a bit of you could start
weaving golden threads between things.
Majid, who eventually joined us for
this, nothing but props for that guy,
for again pulling in what are seemingly
really distal concepts and making
us realize, oh well, if you do do that,
you gain insight pretty quickly.
Then we went on to 35 one which was
which do we start with representation
and or effect? Both in order to model?
So recognizing the importance of partial
information encapsulation that
everything doesn't have to be absolute,
especially over different time frames,
not brain architectures, although that
term was in the title of his paper. But
the role of the architect, someone who
is an applied structure, if there
is such a thing, and the sort of
arbitrary nature of that,
how does it remain arbitrary? Well, by
not being absolute. A real clear way of
understanding the difference between
function and effective connectivity.
That took up a lot of our conversation,
proximal consistency through time and
introduced the term perspective swaps.
I didn't realize that I'd introduce that
into the conversation then. But yes,
that's where it all was seated was back
in January, almost a year ago. Then 35
two. What are we trying to trace?
Separation and or boundedness? The
answer to that, as Magee clearly
concluded, depends on what's available.
So availability not just our regime of
attention. So I thought that was an
incredible thing to bring up a year ago.
Do we keep that? What? That we are the
tracers and the modelers and the
separators and the boundary in the front
of our minds as we analyze situations?
If learning is the sought after effect,
when does that help? Does this lead to
a year of holding up when we are looking
at a target system, say active inference
is subject and when we as observers
might be using active inference in
formal ways, ie. For allowing errors to
not get in the way of new insights.
Assuming insights are a priority for
agents and I was interested in thinking
I wonder how they would be able to get
that into JF's robots,
right? So that's an interesting thing to
me. This is the divide between being a
programmer of a robot where the priority
is learned,
versus dictating how priors are amassed
and organized and then inhabiting a
programming or participatory experience,
one where deconstruction is adaptability
until ultimately something called
complexity dominates the conversation.
In both of those situations, priors and
priorities work in concert, but in the
latter the humanist case are on opposite
sides of a Markov blanket. So at least
partially hidden but also partially
encapsulated. We talked a lot about duck
rabbits that are not riding two
unicycles concurrently, whereas the
robot might. That's an interesting
difference there. And for humans,
riding two unicycles is equal and
complete partitioning or encapsulation.
So that's why it's hard to do. Takes
much training to be able to carry that
out. So that's the was Sajid and
bringing the science and the modeling
and the abductive. And that
was our conversation, even though his
paper was in response to a couple of
other authors arguing that
there's only one way really to model.
And so again, lots of things grew out of
a paper that was meant as a response and
created a whole different ecosystem.
Awesome. Wow. I'll just give a short
thought. Graphical models and network
theory are at the heart, active
inference lab as well as many other
Fields. And what it means to have a
network or a hierarchical model is to
represent a system or a model in terms
of nodes and edges. And exactly what
those nodes and edges are matters a lot.
And in this diagram we had the parable
of Bob and Alice who brushed their teeth
at a similar time because people in that
region just happened to do so. And we
discussed how the statistical
connections between their activities in
terms of the functional and effective
connectivity are not the same as what
is touching what in the real world. And
this very straightforward deflationary
approach to separating the map from the
territory came back again and
again and gain it. Was like we were on
the carousel of functional and effective
connectivity and the map territory and
the math is not the territory. All of
those topics are so central because
when we're looking at those generative
models, we're looking at a graphical
map, not a picture of the
territory. And it's easy, even when you
know, to forget.
And again, I often wonder how because
Daniel reminds me, no, people vote which
papers we're going to do. And sometimes
it's just availability of authors. But
the next paper, which was 36, could not
have been a better coordinate
with Majid's work. It was like the
perfect follow up. Matt and Giovanni's
work on modeling ourselves.
Yes. Give an overview. Go for it.
36 was the importance of working
backwards. The way that you and Bleu
set up the entire paper was, well,
we're going to go to the end and we're
going to work our way back through this
paper just so that it makes sense.
Because I think there was a bit
of a woo woo kind of sense from
reading the paper because it was very
deeply philosophical. Also.
Introduction the claim that in order for
internal representations to be wiped
out, we need to marginalize the unit,
call an action really radical, as if
adding an exclamation point to your
claim somehow changes the relationship
of an action which is a part to the
entirety, which is a whole. So when
you guys first picked up Parr and you're
doing the dot zero already, there was
like, okay, I wonder what we're getting
into here. You also asked indirectly how
artists indirectly how artists, people
with good entorhinal who are good
external external representationalists
maybe have a different gapping or a way
of entangling or both the
organizational, structural and content
related and functional aspects as either
representative or non representative
within parameters. You had a nice table
there set up which, boy, you got a lot
of shelf life out of it. It was useful
for all three livestreams. What I found
most interesting was that to be an
activist meant to you the use of simple
heuristics means control mechanisms do
not need to get to the level of
sophistication more than what
short, catch and long. You had a great
diagram of the baseball Karl hitting it
out of the park. Categorizing the FEP
equals you can be all over the map.
Does that mean we can engineer a bridge
to everywhere? Which was one of the
questions I'd written down, actually,
after watching you and Bleu do the dot
zero, then in the dot one, how does
transition go from materialized to non
materialized and then back? And that
brought us to the idea of what's stable
and what's dynamic juggled as a process
of predictivity in order for
representation and non representation to
coexist. This was the great thing they
are bedfellows. Dean and Bleu debated
the scale freeness and the scale
friendliness of science. I. E.
Observations, recordings, analysis and
prediction. So modeling ourselves in
real time with Daniel substituting
disciplinary for generalization as
modeler strategy, the question was
raised around what must exist pre plan,
pre model. And then I don't know the
lady's name who joined us for the
Danielle Daniel,
we got into some really interesting
loops with your table.
Again, we were looking at
organizational, structural and content
related as probably more stable things
that we want to anchor with those edges
and nodes represented and not kind of
moving around all over the place or
without edges. You can have a gap.
Like, there was a point that came up was
the black lines separating the rows and
the columns, were they solid
or were they actual gaps? So that was
kind of interesting. And then there was
a functional as radical dynamic and
dependent on those stabilities. Now is
modeling ourselves how, when, where,
what if and which? If we act, how does
that impact the model that we believe
exists as we boundary cross, which
again, if you take it to the stuff that
Bijan is talking about on an
organizational level, that's
combinatorially exclusive. So it's
interesting that how we model ourselves
has a huge impact on how do we model
ourselves as an organization, as a
weave, that which we'd like to remain
constant with, that which we'd like to
see changed. So that was modeling
ourselves. And again, Matt and Giovanni
didn't show up, but man, would have been
awesome to have them there and kind of
lead that circus because it was great.
It was great debate between Bleu and I
because she really wants science to be
seen as it, and I really like science to
be seen as specific. And you are the
great moderator and said, no, it's both.
So I was 36 bottling ourselves. Wow.
Yeah, I totally forgot about Karl
hitting. It out of the park. About Karl
Bonds.
Fantastic. Hitting the particle out of
the Parr and about where is
representation? Oh, representation.
Where art thy sting? It was too
fun. It was too fun. And also, just so
people know, the live stream page
has the slides. For every
single live stream that we're
discussing,
you can find the live stream, the title,
the paper, the transcript, the GitHub,
where you can contribute to the journal
as well as the slides. So when we're
pulling slides, you can also look at
them. So, yeah, this was 36 was awesome.
All right, 37. 37.
Free Energy a user's guide by Stephen
Francis Mann, Ross Payne and Michael
Kirchhoff from 2021.
You want to take a first pass?
Well, I just remember
that as much as I'd
like to be able to say I could do the
math if somebody else does the
math and I can follow along at my own
pace, this is where I learned Jacob's
gift. Basically,
that's what my first pass is. I know
when I'm in the presence of people who
could go a lot further on that plane
than I can.
The paper is an excellent users
guide or introduction. One memorable
section was on this trilemma
or trilectic of general or
philosophical claims, mathematical
claims and empirical claims. And they
went through edge by edge and they asked
how do claims from each of those three
vertices justify
each other? And so we hear that
all the time people speaking about
active inference in other areas. Well,
because the brain is this way, we use
this equation or we use this equation
because the brain is this way or because
of this philosophical belief, we use
this equation. It's like seeing it laid
out that way brings a huge
amount of rigor. And it also helps us
understand that rigor is not just
increasingly technical math. Rigor
includes the relationships among
mathematical, philosophical and
empirical claims from different Fields.
So that was one key takeaway for me and
another was the
three piece, the tale of three piece.
And it was a focus of the paper to
point to the unconventional way in
which preferences are utilized. Active
inference Lab which is not as a reward
or a goal function but rather something
that is kind of the fundamental
frequency of the generative model. And
so you have entities striving to return
to the bottom of the bowl in terms of
the path of least action, in terms of
the frequency that they want to be at
and that is the embodiment of
preference. And as we came to see later,
homeostasis and allostasis but there
isn't some sort of dual track between
what is and what should be.
Rather there's a bowl that represents
what could be and is and should
be through its shape and it's about the
ball moving on that shape by which
preferences come to be enacted. So that
was something that was pointed to and
very approachable and they talked a lot
about how they situated the audience of
the work in terms of wanting to speak to
philosophers who really did want to
learn about what free energy principle
is about. One of the things that I got
kind of reinforced in my mind is because
I kind of believe that priors are on one
side of a Markov blanket and priorities
are on another. What that tail of three
P s kind of in my head gave me a
little bit of latitude on was.
Preferences can be on either side of the
blanket. They can literally cross
through. Preferences can pair up with
your priors. You can figure out what
those things are that have been sort of
burned into your neuro desire
lines and they can also preferences can
also be working with your your
priorities in this moment right as you
find yourself now okay, this is what the
niche is, the information, the niche is
sharing with me. But what's my priority,
what's my preference as well. So that
was what the three piece thing I
remember now when we were talking about
that going, okay, don't get the three
things mixed up. Give each one of them
their time in the spotlight.
All right? Live Stream 38 was Evolution
of Brain Architectures Force Predictive
Coding and Active Inference by Giovanni
Pezzulo, Thomas Parr, Karl Friston from
December 2021. And the
topic here is so important what
is the evolutionary neurophysiological
basis of cognition? And how do complex
cognitive phenotypes arise at a
developmental timescale, at an
ecological timescale, and ant an
evolutionary timescale? And where this
paper eventually takes us is
into thinking about the graphical models
again. Remember what we discussed just a
few slides ago about graphical models,
the graphical models which enable
or facilitate or underlie different
kinds of functional outcomes,
and then how structural modification on
graphical model architectures enable
different traits to emerge,
diverge, duplicate, and innovate.
And so here we see on the right side,
it's a tree of options, starting from a
relatively simple initial graphical
model, how different kinds of
modifications, duplications, et cetera,
can result in the kinds of functional as
well as structural phenomena that we
observe in living creatures today. And
whether that's the redundancy of gene
regulatory networks or the paralyzed
architecture of the mammalian cortex,
these are the kinds of phenomena that
this paper set out to bridge the
gap with between simply representing
things as they are as graphical models
and understanding. What if you weren't
just studying the amp brain today,
but what if you were studying the ant
brain over its phylogenetic history?
How would those generative model models
be changing? How do things like temporal
depth or intermodal fusion come into
play? And so that was a nice paper
that connects to evolution and a bunch
of other behavior areas. Really helped
me understand or confirmed in my mind
that there's a big difference between a
person who makes a model and somebody
who has to interpret somebody's third
party model. Because I remember going
through this, I felt like I was learning
on the fly, because even as I was
reading the paper, there was a lot there
to try to parse and just having to be
able to converse with you in Bleu. And I
think Esteves was a part of this one as
well for a bit of time.
Made it a lot easier for me to kind of
understand as an interpreter of models
as opposed to somebody who's, here's my
model. What do you think of it? It was
taking some of these really complicated
models that other people have designed
and then trying to make it into
something that I had adopted. Nice.
Okay. Live stream. 39 morphogenesis as
Bayesian inference a variational
approach to pattern formation and
control in complex biological systems.
By franz Kuchling karl Friston georgi
georgiev and Michael Levin this paper
took what in many other situations are a
mathematics of structurally stable but
dynamically signaling architectures like
the brain and considered the case of
structurally volatile dynamics
signaling structures. And so they
focused on one of the key model systems
in the leaven lab, which is the
plenarian morphogenesis. And upon
cutting this animal,
it quickly reforms into a
selfsimilar body plan.
So that has implications that are being
developed in a whole host of areas
related to health and development and
disease. And the paper uses
a somewhat technical Variational
Bayesian mathematics,
which we also jumped into. And we had
Franz join us here
in the office overlooking some gray
featureless landscape and had
just incredible insights
to share. And we talked about the
environment, what are developmental
priors and trajectories, what are
preferences over morphologies. And this
really opened up the discussion from,
as mentioned, ant the beginning systems
that have a structural stasis, that do
signaling in that structural stasis,
like all the computers are hooked up and
now they're talking to each other, but
they're hooked up the way they're hooked
up. Well, what if the computers can
change how they're hooked up? Or what if
they're moving around? That is another
space that also connects us to a lot of
the physics of the embodied world.
Maybe there's friction, maybe there's
viscosity, maybe there's a
razor that splits two halves from each
other. And it
was a great discussion to see how the
mathematics of the Variational Bayesian
approach is able to accommodate
these different focal systems which
speaks to the generalizability of active
inference. There are a lot of formalisms
there, but it didn't feel formal talking
with Frank and it just felt like
the possible with regeneration had a
whole bunch of Fields that yet to be
explored and the kind of openness
thinking openness that opens
up possibility. That was really cool
about that live stream set. Awesome.
All right, 40. Who could forget
a free energy principle for generic
Quantum systems? 2021 paper.
In fact, a year and a day ago by
Chris Fields, Karl Friston, James
Glazebrook and Michael Levin. So this
paper we
needed to situate ourself on
one hand here represented as the X axis.
Sometimes we find ourselves going back
and forth between more talking about
free energy principle and active
inference, other times discussing
literature or ideas that are outside of
the free energy principle and then
orthogonally. We can think about this
continuum between not quantum and
quantum perspectives from physics.
And we were in the upper
right quadrant or another way of saying
that is we were everywhere because we
were quantum and non quantum and we were
in FEP. We had the authors join
for both of the streams,
the 40.1 and 40.2. So here
we are with Bleu and Esteves, us and the
authors. And every
sequence of symbols that these fellows
added was immense.
And to be able to make
that daredevil jump across
the Grand Canyon and connect the most
advanced perspectives on quantum
mechanics, quantum physics, quantum
computation, unconventional computation
more broadly today, for example,
thinking about the perception, action
and memory phenomena in terms of
repeated measurements of a quantum
observer with their reference frame and
looking ant the holograph. It was a
great and memorable sequence.
It literally materialized the bridge to
everywhere, being in that upper right
quadrant, which is a fascinating thing
because I don't know how you engineer a
bridge to everywhere, but the
possibility means you have to open up to
more than somewhere. And I think that
was, again, one of
those sets where you're kind of going,
am I really doing well? You wouldn't say
this, but I would say this. Am I really
doing this? Am I really having a
conversation? Do I get to sit at the
same room with people of this capacity?
It was really fantastic. And I got to
talk to Mike Levin for privately after
that because, yeah, the idea of
prediction matter expertise intrigued
him. So that was very cool. Great.
Wow. All right. Carrying through 41
extended active inference constructing
predictive cognition beyond skulls,
by axel constant, andy clark, Michael
Kirchhoff, and karl Friston. So here we
had the all star team. We had Bleu,
you and I. Trust is like glue. If you
don't have it, you won't be able to
stick together. And our team
talked about trust active inference lab
models. And I remember this section of
the discussion where we had two systems,
the Bleu and the orange. And we
discussed what is their border, what is
their interface? Is it another region?
But then if it's another region, isn't
there a region that borders that and
what is on the outside of that? And so
how does all that connect to extended
cognitive systems? Extended relative to
what? And so this
topic of extended inference was dealt
with thoroughly here,
and the mathematics and the applications
of extended cognition are so
promising. I also remember you
discussing the difference between a type
of active versus a passive offloading.
There's a difference between somebody
writing a code on a Post It note that
only they know. So if they look at it
later, it's like it helps them remember
what they were thinking of. But to
somebody else, it doesn't mean anything,
and it doesn't do anything as just notes
on paper versus JF creating
a robot and sending it into the
environment. Yes, it might still need
recharging and so on. So it's not like
it's totally disconnected, but it's
doing things actively. And that kind of
active or passive offloading
and the way that that facilitates our
cognitive goals was very rich
discussion. Axel being
the first author of this,
to me, he's like Sajid. He brings in
active coherence, and how long
do you stick with something before you
no longer carry
something on? He's such a good
explainer of you realize that
the environment is actively inferring
you as much as you are inferring it.
That's really hard for people to get
their minds wrapped. The first time you
hear that, you're kind of like, what?
But he does such an amazing job of
explaining that it doesn't seem like
people talking about some silly thing
like fairies dancing on the head of a
pin, you actually go, Wait a second,
you're right. It would have to the
environment would have to be
scrutinizing me as much as I'm
scrutinizing and and trying to figure it
out. Nice. All right. 42.
Robot navigation as hierarchical
hierarchical active coherence by Ozan
Catal, Timberbellan Tune, von Deneve
Bart Dot and Adam Saffron this paper
was an incredible example of applied
active inference. They in this
paper represented the full rainbow
from conceptualizing a generative model
to implementing it and making a robot
that actually enacts that generative
model in a warehouse setting. And what
that warehouse setting required from the
generative model was that there was two
levels at which the generative model was
playing out. At the higher level, which
we were thinking of in terms of
strategy, the robot decides where it
wants to be, where it prefers to be,
and where it is. At a lower level,
which we connected to tactics is related
to the kinds of bodily moves that it can
engage in. It's more movement
affordances. And this
discussion facilitated a lot of action
into the math, the computation, the
embodiment, the robotics, and give some
of the clearest examples of applied
hierarchical model modeling that came
back again and again and again.
So that was fun. All right,
43. Paper 43 was Predictive
Coding a Theoretical and Experimental
Review by Beren Millidge and Neil Seth
and Christopher Buckley. This paper
was quite a doozy. It was very
mathematical and quite long. The
memorable part of this paper to me was
collaborating with Maria on the Dot
zero. And Maria's
philosophical knowledge with predictive
processing took us way back.
And that was rooting
the discussion in the ancients and
thinking about world knowledge,
traditions and ant and Helmholtz. We
hear a lot more about that kind of 1718
1900 philosophy time.
But this pulled us
temporarily back and helped
bridge the math of this paper,
which was technical to the ways
that people have simply perceived,
cognized acted and thought about the
world around them. And then to speak to
the math, this paper almost the entire
thing before something like the last
several pages. It's about hierarchical
predictive processing architectures,
but there's no action to be found. It's
just about inference, inference going up
and down, priors and observations and
prediction errors, all of that. And then
at the end, oh, yeah, we're going to be
doing inference on action. We're going
to be doing active inference. And with
that tiny twist of the
knife, active inference becomes.
And so it's just amazing to see how
purely inferential architectures,
when they're doing inference on action,
the consequences of action are taken
into account. Policy selection is
treated as a formal thing to do
inference on. You get active inference,
and it really isn't too much more
complex than that. And then just a last
point, just like we had the three areas
of claims justifying each other from
Livestream 37 with the general claims,
mathematical and empirical claims. We
had another triangle in 43.
So here we had on the top
biological systems and what they were
doing. On the left we had philosophy and
qualitative claims, and on the right we
had formal quantitative claims. And so
we made another triangle with pretty
much the same three vertices, which is
mathematics, philosophy and empirical
biological phenomena. And we took
another first principles pass on
constructing those three areas and what
are the nodes, what are the edges, and
how are inference and action at the
heart of all of it?
All right, 44 44
was the Therapeutic Alliance active
Coherence Lab the Role of Therapeutic
Touch and Synchrony from 2022 by Zoe
McParlin, Francesco Cerritelli, Karl
Friston and Jorge SVIS. So this paper
was awesome. Also here, from the
screenshot of the event, we have Iain
Tennant with the Inner Sense Channel and
Project, who saw this paper,
brought it to our attention, said, I
want to facilitate this discussion,
and I want to connect exteroception and
the Therapeutic Alliance in a Modern
context to active inference. And I want
to bring in these awesome authors and
make this a conversation that really
hits home. And so thanks, Iain,
for joining and helping. That way, the
paper focuses on the Therapeutic
Alliance, which is like the clinical or
medical or therapeutic niche.
It's the people in the room, it's the
receptionist, it's the nurses, it's the
surgeon, it's the physical rehab
practitioner, it's the family of the
patient, it's the patient themselves,
it's the physical surroundings. And to
be able to very broadly discuss
that vital setting while
connecting it to key active inference
topics like generative models,
synchrony and so on, as well
as to see their delightful figures
and the way that they represented the
same bunch
of authors joining for both of the
discussions. And it was
an awesome series.
All right.
This 145,
this is when I come back from the dead,
and this is what I walked into.
I knew there was a reason why I wasn't
called away. It was because of 45.
45 was the free energy principle, made
simpler but not too simple. By Karl
Friston, Lancelot Costa, North Sage,
Conor Heins, Kyle ulholtzer Grigorios,
a pavliotis, Thomas Parr well,
I think the best way to summarize or
crystallize the experience of this
stream was Bleu, and I spent many
hours preparing for the dot zero. We
were having separate meetings and doing
asynchronous work to really work through
and understand the mathematics of this
paper. And we did the 45.0
in May. It was all great. We Beren
looking forward to June. We had invited
the authors. We didn't really know what
was going to happen. And it was several
minutes after the hour where we were
supposed to start. And so we usually
just try to start on the hour or a few
minutes after the hour. Why wait
longer? And we just didn't
have anyone else on stream. So we said,
all right, this is it. We floundered
through the dot zero. Let us swim again
into the one. Yes, please. Dean, I'm
sorry, but you're not telling the whole
story when you are completely out of
your niche. And you guys worked so hard
to make sure that you could adapt for
this, but then you took the the year
courage and the strength to literally
jump out of the ocean into the boat.
And then all you wanted was come on.
It would be wonderful if somebody could
show up and at least tell us that
jumping out of the ocean was a good
thing to do. And then just like that.
Just a few minutes after, we started to
come. Along and say, hey, how's it
going? Here catch and release. It was so
amazing. You may
not believe that it was that big of a
deal, but it was. And it was amazing.
Yeah. Just a few minutes after starting
with the two of us, first Karl Friston
joined, and then several minutes later,
Thomas joined. So,
yes, it was one moment,
but it spoke to putting it out there and
being ready to show up and being ready
for others to show up, but also for
these two sessions that both Karl and
Thomas joined for. For those who want to
know about the mathematics of active
inference, there's many miles
to go with making it accessible,
rigorous and applicable. So, not to be
denied, but if somebody wants to know
the absolute state of the art, these
conversations, you're hearing it
directly and the questions and the
discourse are 100% approachable.
So this was just some of the highest
density learning and higher
learning. It was an institute of
higher learning. If you want evidence
of naivete, which is not
something you want to remain as all your
life, but those moments when you allow
yourself to be naive and how that can be
a feature, watch this. If you
ant a first step, you might look at
going, I don't know anything about
active inference. Just still, you may
not understand some of the things that
were discussed, and that doesn't matter.
What you really will appreciate is the
generosity.
Yes. Great. All right.
46. So 46 was active. Inference models
do not contradict folk psychology. By
Ryan Smith, Maxwell Ramstead and Alex
Kiefer So what is there to
say? We are folk psychology.
We are them. And this is also a topic
that people bring up all the time. Oh,
preference. Are we talking about like,
that? I prefer to have this happen in my
life. Belief. Are we talking about what
it feels like to believe something? And
this paper just absolutely squarely
targets those questions. And the
conclusion is in the title for the
authors. It's not a reification of folk
psychology. It's not chapter two on folk
psychology. It's not a nullification,
it's not a contradiction. It is a
non contradiction, which is exactly
what it sounds like, which may infuriate
those on any side of multiple fences.
So it was a great conversation because
the topic was so directly tangible
and accessible. We did want to connect
the math and formalism active inference
lab to how people talked about folk
psychology, which is just like us day to
day, talking about our feelings. So that
was an amazing concept. And also the
sort of fun stream memory was
I used social media to communicate
that the dot zero was beginning, I
guess, on June 14 here, and Ryan Smith
just says, hey, I don't know if I'm
going to be free later, but I'm free
now. So we had Ryan in the saddle
for the dot zero, which was
the. First time we ever had the
first. Time we ever had an author join
and bring that kind of insight into the
dot zero. So class
was held, Court was in session,
and Ryan has joined multiple times and
has so much incredible clarity on the
math and on the psychology and the
applications of active inference.
Anyone studying his publication or
presentation career can know that. So it
was a great conversation with Ryan and
then also with Alex Kiefer joining
in the subsequent discussions. And Dean,
you brought so many fun images and
motifs to bear. It was
just like it was such a fun house.
Well, here's the thing. And again, this
was by June, right? We started in
January trying to figure out, what do
the lines between mean? Right?
So is active inference a divider?
Active inference lab an enveloper? What
this paper said was, it's not
contradictory to appreciate that it
could be both, that if we have a circle,
you can be inside with the spokes or you
can be outside and be the contact
service. If it's a divider,
it can be on either sideline. But if it
is both, then why
would you always feel that you're doing
something wrong by holding up both?
Right? Why is both the contradictory
aspects of this, which again,
encouraged me and my mintu I
don't care how you want to do it. You
can collapse past that. But if you want
to get to fractalization,
fractalization being the moment that
you're literally in the gap or on the
line or on the boundary, right.
That's what affords fractalization is
the fact that you don't necessarily go,
well, that's action prediction. And
Clark. We're done. No, I have to stick
to something simpler because I will not
accept a contradictory space. There are
times for absoluteisms, but there's also
what Ryan was pointing out, which is
that maybe that's a feature. Maybe this
ability to see both is something we
should just you don't have to accept
again, counterfactuals, what if you did?
So it was really good. And then Alex
showing up afterwards, kind of plain
cleanup. It was really cool. Yes. So
that was taking us to the end of June.
We then took. A few weeks off of
discussing papers, and in that inter
semester break, we came to 47.
So I'll let you describe 47. It was
active inference and abduction. 2021 by
Ativeco, Piateran and Majid Beni and
an active dynamic social cognition and
active inference by And S. Hipolito and
Thomas Vaness. 2021. Yeah. Well,
again, I guess there was an attention
on my part to get, first of all, muster
up the courage, because these people
have spent a lot of time putting these
papers together. But my sense of it was
I've got both eyes open. I'm not focused
on instrumentalism or
action or taking a realist stance or
taking a non realist stance. And yet
there was all of this conversation
around those things as to which
one entails the other or which one came
first. And all I wanted to do was
hold the papers up side by each. And
rather than having people having to
defend one side or the other, I wanted
to hold it up as here's, two sides to
the same coin. We are on the edge of
this coin. Now, looking down on both,
what does that imply? That's essentially
what that was about, because I think at
the core or the heart of prediction
matter expertise, not just active
inference as something that we can
subjectify, but that we can act upon in
formal ways, not just informally.
That's when you know you've
entered the divide or you're on the
boundary, which leaves it up to you as
the person now that's taken up those
coordinates to do things like we're
doing today. Reflect back on what got
you here. Was it one leg or the
other? Right. It's like saying, oh,
well, it was my left leg that got me
here. Well, it was, but it was also the
right leg. So how do you square that in
some of these debates where people,
like I said, they invest a lot of time
and energy and effort into trying to
make sure that what they're saying is
correct, to the point where they almost
feel like they have to defend something
because it narrowly fits.
And I wouldn't argue against that. But
if we're talking about both scale free
and scale friendly, which we are, I
think we all kind of accepted that.
Now then, how does that work?
And mejee, despite the fact that he was
not under the most optimal health
conditions, was super kind, showed up
and once again graced us with trying
to explain some things, despite the fact
that I know he wasn't in the best
of cognition to do that. So, again,
another shout out for Mashid Beni and
his willingness to go the extra mile.
Yes. And for you in breaking the
one paper per series speed limit and
having us consider two papers
wholeheartedly. So that was hopefully it
was helpful. That's all I was hoping is
that it wouldn't be seen as being
disrespectful because we weren't giving
enough attention over to something. We
were actually entertaining availability
with attention. Again, we were mintwing
things. That was cool.
Thank you. Thank you.
48 communication as socially
extended active inference lab and
ecological approach to communicative
behavior. By Ramit and Pierre Jorge.
This paper brought together a lot of the
topics that we've mentioned earlier.
Communication, extended cognition,
social.
And we had
you, Bleu and I with Remy both
times. What can you say?
Remy is a great defender of an action,
fantastic defender of an action. And he
also has partial encapsulation. Whether
he would have described it as that or
not, he is a partial encapsulator.
So there you go.
Yeah,
it was awesome to have him on. And the
open endedness of the conversation as we
took a look on the social, which can get
one Costa from the first
moment, and maybe that's not even a bad
thing, but we lost more than we've ever
found in that niche
of exploring and discussing. All right,
getting into the last three papers here.
Yeah. And the reason why I mentioned the
gap between 46 and 47 was
because we came back with a fury,
and we were mad at anyone.
We were angry, but we were furious.
And we had some incredible streams.
So almost center in
representing that for me is in
Livestream 49, a worked Example of
the Bayesian Mechanics of Classical
Objects by Dalton Sakthivadivel Devel.
So for this paper, Ali Yacob
and our colleague Conor, we met weekly
for about two months to prepare
for this discussion,
because this paper,
and more generally, Dalton et
al's. Advances in merely 2022,
have transformed the status of active
inference in the free energy principle.
If you want to learn more about what
that really means, check out Live Stream
49. Ali Yakub
and under put in a ton of work. We
worked as hard as we could leading up to
the dot zero, and then Dalton took
us on a journey in the dot one and the
dot two. We couldn't have asked for
a better elucidation or a more
enthralling presentation of Bayesian
physics. I really mean it. And whether
you're working in classical
thermodynamic or quantum mechanics,
or whether you're not familiar with
those areas, this direction
of work and specifically the
presentation and the answers that Dalton
provides and just the spirit that he
brought are absolutely memorable.
So I'll just give you a little aside.
This is the only time on any live stream
ever where instead of playing music,
when I'm doing my workout, my third
listen my third listen of
the dot one of 49 one was while I was
working out, because it's that good.
And it had to be my third listen,
because the first two listeners, I was
just, like, having to pick my job off
the floor. But by the third time, I
wanted to listen to it a third time.
Instead of listening to music, I was
listening to you guys work through this
stuff. And I was just like, this path
integral stuff changes everything.
Yeah. Just briefly, for the conceptual,
here are the three phases of Bayesian
mechanics using a system and a scheme
that's presented in this research and in
earlier research by Dalton and Maxwell
et al. One setting
is where a ball is resting on the ground
and it's not moving. That is kind of
like a distribution, a belief
distribution that's getting new input,
but it's not updating. It's just getting
the exact information it expects. It's
not updating, it's not moving. In
contrast, when new information is
provided, the prior updates to the
posterior and it moves to
track the mode of the new optimum.
So that's like if you had a ball on a
staircase and you pulled one stair and
it fell down to the next one, and you
pulled the next stair and it fell down
to the next one. Those both
represent taking densities over states,
like preference as a state,
observation. As a state. States can
change through time, but they at any
given time, are state based,
in contrast. And that's where we have
the non equilibrium steady state nest
density. So all the discussions we had
about non equilibrium thermodynamics and
non equilibrium steady states, all of
that nest density discussion is on the
states. What some of these recent
developments in path integrals gauge
theory, caliber theory, maximum cal, as
well as the dual the discovery
of Dalton about the duality between the
constrained maximum entropy principle
and the free energy principle when we
calculate densities over paths. There
does not need to be a ness assumption or
a discussion of a mode. But you can get
path tracking, path of least action
tracking without appealing to
this intermediated nest.
It's only been a few months, but there's
so much more to come here on
the mathematics and on the applications.
It's incredible. And a year ago,
we couldn't have said any of this.
So a lot has happened in active
inference, but in the 49 dot zero,
you'll see us grappling with
the eras of active inference
and FEP and about what phases in epochs.
And even now we can acknowledge
that we're in a post Dalton era.
Yeah, and it's funny, because before
hearing this, it almost felt like you
had to go down the vertical and then
across the horizontal, and then down the
vertical and then across the horizontal.
And then all of a sudden, he introduced
the wheels and the bike went riding
down the steps. That's how different
it became. Now, that's still a bumpy
ride. You have to go quite quickly to
smooth things out. Right.
Smoothing. But that's essentially
how dramatic it was like it was like
introducing the wheel.
Yeah.
It'S only a wheel. Right.
Wheels within wheels now.
All right, 50. So in 50,
the paper being discussed, I didn't
bring it in, was exteroception as
modeling, alastasis as control,
with Eli Senate and Jordan Thorough,
who are here as well as several other
authors, karen Quigley and Lisa Feldman
Barrett, maybe some others. So what
would you and on 50. Well, just that
again, you would see that interraception
would be its own field and allostasis as
being a separate field. And then there's
this lab somewhere in northeastern
United States that's trying to DeField
bring things into an opportunity to
be integrated. And it was fascinating to
try to see how people address
operationally and formally things that
seem to be pretty messy and hard to
manage when we're talking about things
like we don't have necessarily access to
the information in a mathematical way.
It's called a feeling. So how do
we blend those things together? And
again, I'll be honest, I was the most
skeptical and became a fanboy after
having great conversation with Jordan
and Eli. Yeah, that was
memorable discussions.
Eli gave a presentation that
helped us really, like lock in
conceptually how they were framing it
and what they did. Some of the
statistical transformations are
evergreen in the sense that there was a
capacity curve, a probability density
implied by a capacity curve, and then a
responsiveness that was a log
probability density. And now whenever
we see one of these, we see all of them,
right? Because they're all just
transformations, either PDF to CDF or
log probability densities. Check out the
stream to learn more. But whenever we
see these, we can kind of see all of
them. When we see one and see
one thing, see multiple things, learn
one thing, learn multiple things.
It was awesome. All right, and the final
Livestream discussion paper. So this was
canonical neural networks perform active
inference. 2022 Paper by Takuya IsomerA,
Hideaki Shimazaki, Andy Clark Friston
and it
was a fun and an honor and a learning
journey for me. I prepared the dot zero
myself, which hadn't happened for a
little bit of time by then. This was
just in November. And then in both the
dot one and the dot two, it was just
Takuya and I. And the paper's
implications are so stunning
in light of the prevalence of neural
networks and artificial intelligence
machine learning. The paper supports
a claim that was agent within an earlier
research paper by the authors. But they
kind of completed the loop in this paper
to really reinforce it that
as per their figure one, every neural
network canonical neural network listen
to the Livestream slash. Read the paper
to learn more. Every neural network in
engagement with the environment through
perception, cognition and action can be
understood using the particular
partitioning that we use in active
inference, where the generative process
engages the generative model of an
agent. Also in terms of perception,
cognition and action. In fact,
the training by which agents can learn
from their own experiences about what
to do in the future is also analogous as
well. And here we see some message
passing reflecting that the discussion
was technical, yet asked
basic questions, and everybody
who works with neural networks or knows
somebody who does, I'd recommend that
they check out this discussion and
paper because it was a perfect example
of making the bridge.
And here we see the min two of min two
s. We see the partition between a
generative model and a generative
process and then two views on that being
juxtaposed. And so now when we see a
neural network, we can think that
there's a generative model that might
reflect the semantics of what the neural
network does, even if the structure of
the neural network is arcane. And in
contrast, when we see a generative
models, we can imagine that there are
some neural network architectures with
arcane topologies that implement that
generative model. And so as we build
these rigorous Bridges, we see more and
more with the same visual input.
And so that is really advancing the
field. And also, again, could not have
been Seth a year ago. Is it building a
bridge to everywhere or is it moving in
that direction? Let's go
to Reflections. Okay.
If we built Bridges to everywhere, it's
like paved paradise. Put up a parking
lot. We wanted people to be able to
drive all over paradise and park
wherever they wanted. So we paved it.
We put up a parking lot. I don't think
that's what's happening. What is
happening?
Well,
again, I get the ambition of
trying to take some statistical
models and see where they might be
inserted in things that are going out
and doing the exploration.
See that my
Continuum attention active inference lab
is because I believe it is a
way when you're ready, it is a way of
generating way more insight, way more,
AHA moments than what I
think is a kind of unidirectional
approach or a hierarchical approach that
says, amass all
this information, put it, synopsize it
into your own, synthesize it, synopsize
it and feed it back to a board
or a review committee or something like
that. I understand how that works and
why that serves a certain agenda or
intent. I think what active inference
does is it opens things up so that you
do not have a ladder to climb or
at least they haven't invented a ladder
to everywhere. I think that's what it
does is it creates options and
possibilities and sees things as
it could be this, it could be that. So
from a humanist standpoint,
it just makes available, provides
affordances that's kind of at the Jorge
of the work that's being done.
It enables the use of things like
counterfactuals, why that matters,
why it's just as important to ask what
if as it is to ask what is.
These are all things that I think don't
even have to be stuck in narrative
spaces. I think it's what you now
can choose to try
and make some sense out of. And I think
a lot of times in order for people to
become specialists and experts at
something they have to really focus
their attention on something. But I
think what active inference says is the
more times you vary your attention
and change your attentional space, I e.
Make yourself available to ideas and
phenomena that you otherwise would
ignore because you think it
doesn't really matter in this particular
moment, the more AHAs, the more insights
you yourself gain. So I
don't know that we're paving over
anything. I don't think that the bridge
has to be something positive and
material. In fact, as we talked about
at that very second
set of live streams this year, is the
hidden states hidden because a
shroud something that's material,
something that blinds us to the
situation? Or is it simply something
that we just haven't given our attention
to over yet?
Do I need to build a bridge across
the Grand Canyon, or is seeing across it
to the other side enough? That's what
active inference asks us to explore.
I think if people want to come and find
an opportunity to socialize with other
people around references,
there's work to do that to do with that
around stuff that Bijan Chaos written
about and stuff that Karl has written
about. And those are fantastic
exercises, but I think there's more to
it than that. And I think the everywhere
part is something that, again, it gets
reinforced when you're putting on a live
stream that you put in hours and hours
and hours of preparation on and you
don't know whether or not the person who
actually was the author of the work is
going to be able to show up or not?
Because these are busy people and then
they do. That's an active inference
moment. That's a kind of a dedication to
a philosophy. And I think that's where
Karl said there's a lot of stuff that
still has to be worked out by the
philosophers. Well, I continue along
with Thomas and Dalton to try to work
out what the formalisms and the
operations are. So I think and eye on
each is kind of where we are today.
There's probably less room for people to
say, no, it's one or the other. I think
there's a lot more room to say, well,
if we put this and this and this
together, I wonder what kind of smoothie
that derives.
That's my sense of where we are at the
start of 2023.
Yes, it was
like, in the beginning of the year.
If only we could just pin it down.
Is active inference realist, or is
active inference this way? If we could
just get it on the table on
procrusty's bed, then I
would be able to approach it. I'm too
busy right now. I'm too overwhelmed
right now. It's too complex right now.
It's too ambiguous right now. It's
changing too fast right now. If you
could just stabilize it in this one
dimension, then I'll meet you, and I'll
be ready to talk and out of that
environment, the doorway was
dialogue and getting different
perspectives together beginner
intermediate and beyond. Today it
is becoming a growing ecosystem
of education, research, applications and
service where it's not just that there
can be the coexistence of different
perspectives, it's that there are,
there must be. And we love that.
It seems it seems bit counterintuitive.
But if there is a nature part
to this, one of the things we might
discover at the end of 2023 that are
that there's more pockets of feral and
wild behavior and activity as
opposed to less. That the more times
people come and say, is there a packaged
version? Is there a Disneyland version
of this that I can use as my entry
point? Perhaps what they'll discover is
there's an opportunity when you hit
your ball out of bounds in Costa Rica,
there's a sign that says do not find
your ball. There are scorpions,
there are snakes, and there are
crocodiles. Crocodiles don't just
inhabit the water areas, they literally
hang out in the forest. And so you
respect that, right? Unless you're
going to properly protect your nine iron
ain't going to save you is my point.
But there's a piece of this that's
highly groomed, highly formalized. And I
think there's also a piece of this that
from a behavioral active standpoint,
we might find a year from now is a lot
more enabling, is a lot more feral who
wants to go into those marginal areas
and really poke around a little bit.
And I think again, what people might
find is that active inference isn't a
shield, but it is an anchor. It provides
the organizational, structural and
contentrelated stabilities that
people can anchor to so that they can
then go out and play with those edges
or the non edges. They can function in
ways that they probably didn't imagine
if they believed that active inference
was a ladder to something specific.
So again, there's a creative side of
this that I think a year from now.
Again, I know that there's a bunch of
people in business that want to do
capture work around this and there's a
bunch of scientists that want to get
confirmation and I get that. I get what
their goals are and I respect them.
But I also think there's a connectivity
piece to this that's just percolating
below the surface and that when it's
given a chance to run its course,
it could be amazing in terms of what
people generate.
It made me think a shield is not a
sarcophagus. An anchor is not a
pillar driven into the ocean floor.
Even something that is stabilizing and
defensive must have a
loose tethering and an optimal grasp.
And if it's better to be stabilized,
why not just put the pillar down? Like
that is one direction of thought and
it may be valid locally or at a
meso scale situationally. We're not
looking to resolve these questions in
the abstract. There may be a case where
you do want to get inside the iron
sarcophagus and hide. But when
we are out there figuring and
balancing that with
figuring it out, we need to also
see those two in conversation or
in dialectic. So it's not like we can
just figure it out such that we're going
to derisk and achieve out there.
It's not the work itself. It isn't even
interestingly enough the exact
preparation for the work itself out
there, but also if we're only out there,
so much happens that we lose valuable
opportunities for preflection and
function, and we lose those
opportunities to figure things out while
the iron is hot. And so we
grow and we act infer and we serve less
than we could, which again, may not be a
bad thing, and maybe no lives are lost
for it. But how
to read and speak
between the lines and make sure that the
Active Inference Institute is accessible
to all language and mathematical
backgrounds. As our usage of
the active inference ontology and the
formalisms becomes increasingly
sophisticated, as demands from
industry, from professionalized research
and all of these other sectors become
increasingly intense as well, how will
we be able to provide services
to our community and niche that neither
exactly square with
what their priors are? Because if it
did, they could have done it themselves.
Nor do we want to come from a different
wavelength or planet where the
material are failing
to make impact because they're not
accessible, applicable and rigorous.
Here's an interesting thing to think
about as one of the people who spent
countless hours growing this idea.
I don't think back in January of this
year you could have taken the words from
Sajid, where he was talking about
partial encapsulation and envisioned a
direct application to the idea that the
active inference lab had to be only
partially encapsulated in order for it
to morph into the active inference
institute. These are the
things that we, upon reflection, can
look back and go, well, we were talking
about it as an idea, but here's an
example of where it actually became
true. And I didn't know at the time that
the active inference lab was going to
turn into the institute. That's what
active coherence allows for.
That's what's really fascinating. And
again, I'll say this. If you really want
to learn, go through an exercise like
you and I just went through today,
because it gives you the opportunity to
say, oh, by the way, if you want some
real evidence without pre staging
the idea that I want to prove this. I
want to prove that there's a parcel
encapsulation, just live it out,
migrate through it, go through that
space time, come out the other side,
look back on it and go, wow. I guess
what we were talking about eleven
months and 26 days ago, in fact,
could turn out to be pretty prescient,
because there's no way we could become
an institute today if we didn't leave a
gap open for that possibility. So it's
just really interesting. Again, if you
want active inference to be a repeat
of what you have already been habituated
to, you can make it that, or you can
stick around and kind of go only
mackerel. It wasn't just in theory. In
fact, it materialized in
the ways that the theory said it could,
not would. And that's the bridge to
everywhere.
Well, we put up our
canonical final slide. Thank you, Dean,
for this, Dean, and for all of the
others and everyone who came on.
If you're listening this far,
thank you for your regime of attention.
We are looking to make 2023 and
years beyond it better.
And this was a great year. So it's
no slight on where we've been. It's just
a spiral of developments.
Any dimension or divergence from your
highest preference is either feedback
you can provide the institute or
engagement that you can yourself make
happen. You want to see a certain kind
of stream happen. You want to see
another language other than English.
You want to see a different kind of
educational material become accessible,
either provided as feedback, or let's
figure out how to make it happen with
your engagement. We'll go out there
anytime.
Wow. Well,
no word can close the year,
so we'll just leave it at that. Thank
you, Dean. Thank you. All right. Till
next time, my friend. Till next time.
Act! Infer! Serve! All right.